[Music]
on this wednesday night trying to clear
the air
omicron and the confusion over new rules
for travelers things change on a daily
basis as the u.s detects its first case
of the new variant plus what is the
point of travel bans
bc gets a reprieve from the rain now
people are mopping up the mess it's
fairly confident to say this is going to
be
the most costly disaster in canadian
history rare moment of unity among mps
the unanimous decision to outlaw
conversion therapy
plus from scams to spam and spoofs
they're the worst it's a nuisance and it
can be kind of dangerous the pitfalls to
the technology meant to dial up relief
from robocalls
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we continue to watch the emergence of
the omicron variant tonight it's been
detected in at least 24 countries now
including canada and the united states
the first case identified there is a
fully vaccinated person in california
who traveled from south africa and who
has only mild symptoms the u.s has since
banned travel from southern africa
here's what dr anthony fauci said today
about that
no one feels i certainly don't that a
travel ban is going to prevent people
who are infected from coming to the
united states but we needed to buy some
time to be able to prepare understand
what's going on what is the nature of
this infection what is the nature of the
transmissibility
the wh said today some of those answers
will come in a matter of days canada too
has banned travelers from 10 african
countries including egypt even though
there are already confirmed cases here
and new testing requirements are being
put in place for everyone who flies into
canada from countries other than the u.s
they'll have to take pcr tests on
arrival but the details of how that will
work and why travelers from the u.s are
exempt are among many outstanding
questions abigail beeman begins our
coverage tonight
well i brought some books and my laptop
so if i get stuck
i can work travelers leaving edmonton
are bracing for whatever potential
measures may be in place when they get
back things change on a daily basis with
some annoyance over the new rule that
they'll have to take a second pcr test
upon arrival back in canada and isolate
until it comes back negative well i
think it's very disappointing because i
don't think about is where you're coming
from i mean i could get it at costco
i've had all my shots
my booster i've done everything i'm
supposed to do
and
i want to start living my life i don't
have that many more years
testing all passengers is not happening
at this airport yet and few details
overall as the industry worries about
disruption and backlogs and the holiday
season nears today is our first call
with the government to understand what
they're trying what the intent is two
industry sources tell global news
testing measures are expected to come
into force this weekend the government
will only say capacity is already
increasing it will take time it will the
speed of implementation will also vary
in local airport as for ottawa's
rationale behind new rules officials
want more time to better understand the
new variant accepting it's already here
those might buy some time
spread is inevitable on border closures
the wh is clear blanket travel bans will
not prevent the international spread of
omicron
and they place a heavy burden on lives
and livelihoods the variants already
here and it's going to spread now
based on on local transmission and not
so much on importing
transmission one potential loophole new
border testing rules don't apply to
people coming from the united states
that's a conversation we'll continue to
have right up to today and tomorrow we
need to be prepared and ready if we need
to adjust
that decision to include travelers from
the u.s ministers will only say the
situation is fluid and they're watching
what's happening south of the border
closely meanwhile the entire travel
industry and many canadians are waiting
for specifics on how the new rules will
work and when they'll be in place and
now that it's december what to do about
potential holiday travel plans abigail
beeman global news ottawa
south african officials have described
the travel bans as unduly punitive
especially since western countries have
failed to deliver sufficient vaccines
and logistical support to africa and
dutch authorities say the omicron
variant was already present in the
netherlands before south africa alerted
the world about it as michael couture
reports the who is calling on wealthier
nations to do more to help others before
offering booster shots to its own
citizens
all of us are either in this together or
we're not
you cannot have a pandemic in part of
the world and not in others a call for
more collaboration from the world health
organization as more cases of omicron
are confirmed in more parts of the world
vaccine nationalism is growing and more
and more jurisdictions are looking at
widening booster programs we're
continuing with our booster dose
strategy as well we'll have more to say
about that with respect to age
categories within the next few days
that's in spite of the w.h.o asking
countries to instead divert doses to
lower income nations right now
there is no evidence
that i'm aware of that would suggest
that
boosting the entire population is going
to necessarily provide any greater
protection for otherwise healthy
individuals despite millions of doses
being donated global vaccine inequity
remains massive consider that just 1.7
percent of nigeria's 200 million people
are fully vaccinated compare that to
more than 75 percent of canadians i'm
just coming out of yemen point five not
five point five percent of the
population is vaccinated so you know
it's a humanitarian nightmare ethicists
and epidemiologists say unvaccinated
populations become breeding grounds for
variants
our minister of international
development says canada has enough doses
for boosters and donations we've
committed up to uh right now up to 200
million
doses the equivalent of 200 million
doses
but we're more importantly working with
the world health organizations through
kovacs to making sure it's an equitable
distribution but experts maintain
vaccine equity should be seen as a
threat here at home if you're in a
crowded building and you say your
neighbor doesn't want to buy a smoke
alarm or a fire extinguisher you would
say well i'll buy one for them and make
sure that i'm safe that's exactly what
we have to do here is vaccinate the
world to protect ourselves and until
vaccines have reached every part of the
globe everyone everywhere can still be
susceptible
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
turning now to storm-battered british
columbia the province is dealing with
the third atmospheric river in a series
of back-to-back storms that have
drenched much of the coast for more than
two weeks it's caused more flooding in
already waterlogged areas like
abbotsford and the surrounding farmland
of sumas prairie as heather urex west
reports that's making it difficult to
look ahead to recovery
this is abbotsford underwater again
it's been more than two weeks of dealing
with heavy rain evacuation orders and
flooding and the constant stress and
anxiety is taking a toll so this is the
top of the water rich van laar's dairy
farm was among the many operations in
the sumas prairie overwhelmed by flood
waters for three days the farm sat under
almost a meter of water i had 16 calves
in my garage
in the house so a nice amount of noise
in the house
since then back to back to back storm
systems have made it almost impossible
to focus on recovery we've been in the
cleanup process ever since the big one
hit here and just hoping it doesn't come
back
water from the nooksack river in
washington state has now made its way to
this part of abbotsford near the
trans-canada highway it's flooded this
side street where the water is still
moving traveling down to the sumas
prairie before heading into the fraser
river highway 1 through the fraser
valley remains closed between abbotsford
and chilliwack the tiger dams that were
set up there
on sunday night are in place and have
been effective in preventing the roadway
from being flooded
on tuesday a small number of homes were
evacuated because of localized flooding
but overall the city says its
infrastructure has been coping well this
round
the relentless rains scarring and
submerging the landscape as people here
now start planning to move on
in british columbia's flood zone
communities are isolated and struggling
to survive the situation obviously is
evolving not over days here it's
evolving within hours and minutes and
changing highway 7 a crucial artery in
bc has been hit by a landslide of course
we know with the transcanada closed we
know how important highway 7 is as the
only road corridor where essential goods
can move out of the lower mainland the
coquihalla which is a connector between
vancouver and the rest of bc is still in
pieces and won't reopen for months
already reconstruction bills are adding
up likely to reach the billions it's
fairly confident to say this is going to
be
the most costly disaster in canadian
history
that's because at no time in history
have so many different communities been
hit with one disaster it is not cheap to
rebuild roads to rebuild road lines
to rebuild dikes it's not lost on
federal politicians that just about
every route from bc to the rest of
canada has taken a hit cn rail is still
not operating
cp rail is moving ahead the trans
mountain pipeline is still offline after
the latest bout of bad weather delaying
fuel already being rationed that is in
short supply the significant weather
that we have seen continues to create
challenges for trans mountain and the
transport of fuel through the pipeline
suffice to say normal life is going to
be disrupted for a long time even the
leaders trying to manage this disaster
are struggling to stay afloat we're
going to get through today and then
we've got to get through tomorrow and
many more tomorrows are ahead with the
rain that hasn't stopped its reign of
destruction robin gill global news
vancouver
in newfoundland and labrador cleanup
efforts are still underway from a
powerful late november storm today there
was some good news a portion of the
transcanada highway near puerto basque
reopened to one lane of traffic
record-setting rainfall washed out four
sections of that highway cutting off the
community from the rest of the province
normal ferry service from portabask to
nova scotia is expected to resume
tomorrow
a new study is painting a dim picture of
what's expected to happen in the arctic
researchers from the university of
manitoba project rain will become more
common than snow in the arctic one to
two decades sooner than previously
thought the study published in the
journal nature communications predicts
the shift will happen between 2050 and
2080 depending on how fast the planet
warms it would have huge implications
including permafrost melt and widespread
flooding in august the summit of
greenland's ice sheet experienced
rainfall for the first time in recorded
history
huawei has been waiting years to find
out if it will be allowed into canada's
5g network coming up what the delay on
the decision could be signaling
[Music]
the women's tennis association is
suspending all tournaments in china
including hong kong over concerns about
the safety and well-being of chinese
tennis star pong shui pang has appeared
on video but has not been seen in public
since the beginning of november when she
accused a former high-ranking chinese
government official of sexual assault
the tennis association says it has
serious doubts she is free safe and not
subject to coercion and it fears the
potential risk to other tennis players
and staff in china
the long-awaited decision on whether the
federal government will ban huawei from
canada's 5g networks is expected to
happen in a matter of weeks the u.s u.k
australia and new zealand have all
banned or restricted the
telecommunications giant because of
concerns the network could be weaponized
by the chinese government our chief
political correspondent david aiken is
with me now david where does canada
stand right now on huawei
well you know donna many in canada have
the same fear that huawei's gear if
installed in the main hubs or core of
our telecommunications networks could be
used by the chinese government to spy on
canadians
we continue to follow the advice of our
science our experts our intelligence and
security analysts uh we're working with
uh the various uh various telcos to
ensure that there's a competitive
environment but that of course uh the
safety and protection of canadians is
always there
now huawei for the record swears its
gear will never be used for spying but
the canadian government is also worried
that banning huawei could spark a
backlash by china possibly involving
retaliation against canadian companies
or canadian sectors and so there are
those on parliament hill even inside the
liberal caucus who say the trudeau
government's long delay on making a
decision is in fact the decision the
delay has had the effect of banning
huawei without explicitly doing so as
telecom companies like bell and telus
started buying 5g gear early last year
from other vendors like europe's
ericsson still ottawa will have to
formally make a decision one way or the
other and that decision is expected in a
few weeks it's one of the most
consequential decisions for canadians
for generations to come
now the u.s and australia have in fact
banned huawei from their national
networks the united kingdom has
partially banned huawei so perhaps by
the end of the year we'll find out how
bold canada will be on this donna all
right david aiken in ottawa thanks the
diplomatic dispute between u.s the u.s
and russia has reached a new level the
kremlin has ordered some american
embassy staff to leave russia by the end
of next month u.s diplomatic staff that
have spent more than three years in
moscow have to leave by january 31st the
white house ordered more than 50 russian
diplomats to leave the u.s by june 30.
the biden administration says the
russian embassy staffers must fly home
because their visas are expiring the
kremlin says washington's refusal to
extend those visas amounts to expulsion
the u.s and russia are set to hold
diplomatic talks tomorrow
choice in jeopardy ahead the supreme
court battle reignites over american
abortion rights
there being no dissenting voice i
declare the motion carrier
[Applause]
a rare moment of unity and celebration
in the house of commons today mps
unanimously passed a bill to ban
conversion therapy the discredited
practice of trying to change an
individual's sexual orientation or
gender identity
there were hugs across party lines after
the vote and some tears of joy in the
foyer
it's just a wonderful day for
kids growing up in a world
that i didn't grow up in
and
it's a pretty great day
the bill will now move to the senate
in the u.s a landmark court ruling
guaranteeing the right to abortion is
being tested nearly five decades after
it passed over the years a vocal
minority of social conservatives have
gained political power and chipped away
at a woman's right to choose in some
american states access to abortion is
now severely restricted and as eric
sorenson reports the u.s supreme court
is set to decide whether to restrict it
even further it is the most vehemently
contentious law in american society
abortion as a woman's basic right my
rights as a pregnant person become come
first overturning or limiting the law
could split the country there are 24
states poised to ban abortion if this
law is upheld this is historic day for
the pro-life movement pro-life advocates
want the court to uphold a mississippi
law that bans almost all abortions after
15 weeks of pregnancy even those caused
by rape or incest under roe v wade
almost 50 years ago the supreme court
limited restrictions before about 24
weeks when a fetus was considered viable
mississippi's attorney general says
times have changed and certainly we know
that life can be detected in the womb
much earlier in the supreme court
conservative justice samuel alito
articulated one of the basic pro-life
arguments the rights of personhood begin
at conception or at some point other
than viability liberal justice elena
kagan suggested women's rights are at
stake the autonomy and the freedom and
the dignity
of women to pursue their lives as they
wish to protect their bodily integrity
but this is not the same court as 50
years ago in 1973 the liberal-leaning
warren court by a 7-2 vote made abortion
rights legal in the united states in
2021 there are only three liberal judges
on the court three conservative justices
on the roberts court were joined by
three more appointed by president trump
creating a clear conservative majority
so this is a very frightening situation
right now for women in the us this legal
scholar says new restrictions on
abortion would change the perception of
america as a leading light on women's
rights in canada there's no simmering
debate among the major parties on
abortion but could a change in the u.s
stir things up if our neighbor next door
does this
is there a risk that that will give
more uh impetus to that
kind of movement to start changing
restrictions here the u.s supreme court
may stop short of overturning roe v wade
altogether but some observers believe it
will uphold the mississippi law and that
could spur new anti-abortion laws across
the country by next summer erik sorensen
global news
repelling robocalls next the new tech to
stop nuisance calls will it work for
everyone
you never know who is going to be on the
other end when you answer your phone
these days scammers and robocalls
claiming to be everything from the
revenue agency to the police are having
a field day there is some new technology
that's supposed to stop them or at least
some of them and gaviola explains how it
works
the reason behind this call is that do
you ever feel like these are the only
calls you get one out of every four
phone calls in canada is spam or a spoof
our department has decided to suspend
your social insurance number
they're annoying this call is from
canada revenue agency and can be
deceitful with scammers posing as your
bank the police or even federal agents
it's a nuisance and it can be kind of
dangerous these spoof calls when they're
they're making them they're very
threatening they're very scary and a lot
of the times
people who get them are immigrants who
have fought their way to come to stay in
canada they give talking on the phone a
bad name
these calls are so pervasive i got one
during our morning meeting while i was
talking about this story now we were
supposed to have national screening
technology in place to crack down on
these types of calls in 2019 it's
finally here but it's not going to work
for everyone in order to send the kind
of the proof of identity data along
through it there has to be an unbroken
chain
of modern telephone systems from
beginning to end so if the caller or
receiver is using a landline it won't
work no dice if the call is coming from
outside canada it might not work either
can nothing stop the scourge
universal call blocking that is a system
that is put in place for carriers to
ensure that calls that are made
traditionally through
landlines even over voice over internet
protocol there is a way of blocking
those calls and making sure that those
calls are not spoofed it's not going to
protect you from someone talking you out
of your money on a fraud though the
screening tech is mandatory consumer
advocates say some companies may try to
sell you their own versions too the crtc
unfortunately didn't say that they can't
charge for this new one some consumers
might see this offered in the coming
months with one or two dollar per month
charge maybe more
[Music]
so sorry if you can't get a hold of me
later i'm screening my calls
and goviola global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your candidate is this truck lit up for
the holidays in beaver county alberta
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you